on entend beaucoup parler de wifi 6e je
vous en ai parlé notamment au travers de
différents smartphones qui commence à
avoir la norme wifi 6e on voit qu'il ya
également des boks qui commencent à
arriver en wifi 6-1 alors c'est très
très récent ya très peu de personnes qui
aujourd'hui ont des boks en wifi 6e mais
la question qu'on va se poser c'est dur
qu'est ce que le wifi 6e et est ce que
ça vaut le coup tout de suite
aujourd'hui début 2022 de partir sur du
wifi si ce maillot on y va
de quoi on a besoin pour parler de ça on
a besoin de feuilles on a besoin de
stabilo et on n'a pas besoin de ça alors
déjà on va commencer par essayer de
comprendre ce qu'est le wifi et nous
savions alors le wifi on sait tous que
c'est parce qu'on a tous chez soi c'est
au travers de votre box puis ça fait au
travers de répéteurs bref le wifi c'est
le réseau qui se distribuent chez vous
et qui permet à vos appareils de se
connecter sans fil je pense que là vous
le savez c'est très simple tout le monde
a du wifi sauf que le wifi ya une
numérotation derrière wifi 5 wifi 4 ou
et fils ici aujourd'hui wifi 6e en fait
tout ça c'est énorme et par la wifi
alliance qui gère le réseau wifi au
niveau international et qui définit les
noms voilà ça va vous le savez je sais
pas si vous avez gardé sur votre box il
ya des numéros de bandes de fréquences
en fait historiquement vous avez eu ce
roman accès au wifi 4 wifi 4 vous avez
qu une seule bande de fréquence c'était
du
2,4 gigahertz ça c'est la première bande
de fréquence qu'on avait et qu'on
retrouve toujours aujourd'hui sur son
wifi en wifi 5 wifi six wi fi 6e le wifi
5 en 2013 nous apporter quoi une bande
de fréquences supplémentaires c'est le 5
giguère ça c'est le 5 giga hertz qui est
arrivé au top avec le wifi 5 avec le
wifi 6 on n'a pas vu arriver deux bandes
de fréquences nouvelle le wifi 6 c'était
en 2010 avec le wifi si son art en
théorie un meilleur débit qui permet
d'aller jusqu'à 10 gigabits par seconde
contre 7 gigabits par seconde avant ça
c'est la théorie mais là où le wifi 6e
est intéressant c'est qu'il vient
apporter une note bande de fréquence ou
là on vient grimpé à garder au club on
va des zones un peu on vient grimper aux
alentours des 6 gigahertz donc se situe
par ici
alors c'est pas un jeu de fléchettes
c'est pas une cible ça permet de voir un
petit peu ce que ça vient vous apportez
qu'est ce que vient apporter cette bande
de fréquences supplémentaires ça
plusieurs effets intéressants déjà vous
allez avoir un spectre plus large vous
avez 7 canaux de 160 mes garçons s'en
fout un peu du côté hyper technique de
l'histoire là dessus mais ce qu'il faut
vraiment venir retenir c'est que vous
allez pouvoir faire passer plus
d'informations dans chaque canal par
rapport à ce que vous aviez avec du wifi
6 et du wifi 5 ça permet également autre
chose une bande passante qui va être
plus fluide donc ça c'est cool on a
aussi des canaux plus large et sans
oublier une latence plus faible alors la
latence plus faible ça va être
intéressant notamment pour le gaming
mais pas que vous allez voir cap l'inde
usages différents derrière et qui
permettent de faire évoluer tout un
monde connecté numérique mais pas qu'eux
à la maison et c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi avec le wifi 6 alors
potentiellement vous allez avoir des
débits plus élevés ici qui vous
permettrait d'aller jusqu'à 11 gigabits
par seconde ça reste vraiment intrus
potentiellement mets des guillemets déjà
il vous faut une bonne connexion il vous
faut de la fibre ça sert à rien en fait
si vous voulez parce que si on regarde
en fait vous allez avoir vous votre
maison ici envoyez votre maison elle est
là et elle va être connecté votre maison
au réseau ça c'est le réseau par votre
opérateur si vous êtes connectés en
fibre ça va aller hyper hyper hyper
hyper vite donc vous avez une collection
qui va être très rapide mais si vous
n'êtes pas fibrés à la maison et que
vous êtes je sais rien moi en adsl
encore si vous avez du wifi 6e à la
maison vous n'allez pas vraiment avoir
bénéfices parce que ça va pas aller très
vite donc il faut que derrière vous ayez
de la fibre il faut que sa tartine à
moins que vous soyez sur un réseau fermé
où vous venez à voir en glace comme chez
moi voyez par exemple moi j'ai un as
donc là je peux me connecter directement
plus rapidement parce que je suis dans
mon réseau interne à la maison ce qui
veut donc dire que tout ce qui va se
passer ici va aller vite en wifi 6e ok
ça c'est plutôt bien sauf que et c'est
intéressant le but de ça c'est de se
connecter avec le reste du monde pas
uniquement vous chez vous donc il vous
faut bien évidemment une connexion en
fibre si on veut en profiter et si on
veut que sa tartine voilà ça c'est
matériel alors qu'est-ce que ça permet
effectivement ça au delà d'avoir spectre
plus la jeune bande passante lui denis
latence plus faible et des canaux plus
large ça permet plusieurs trucs si on
revient un peu en arrière je vous dis
jusqu'au bout y fit six vous êtes ici
bande 2,4 gigahertz 5 gigas le fait de
rajouter une bande en 6 gigahertz ça va
déjà dire faire respirer votre bande là
qui des fois peuvent être un petit peu
étouffé si vous avez plein d'objets
connectés à la maison si comme moi par
exemple vous avez des ampoules connecter
si vous avez des éclairages connecter si
vous avez des enceintes connecter un
ordinateur une télé connectée bref le
tout connecté chez vous sans parler de
montres de smartphones et compagnie au
bout d'un moment on va commencer un
petit peu manqué de place l'idée du wifi
6e ça permet de rajouter de la place et
d'apporter une bouffée d'air frais à
votre connexion wifi on peut venir en
rajouter plus en fait et aller plus loin
dans l'internet des objets à la maison
et c'est ça qui est vachement
intéressant mais pas que moi parlons pas
si tout de suite je suis à paris je suis
dans un immeuble et j'ai des voisins
fatalement j'ai les mêmes ne
m'appartient pas complètement et non
quand même pas faux pas décoller donc
j'ai des voisins j'ai voisin l'ag voisin
l'ag voisin l'ag voisins là j'ai des
voisins tous les côtés il ya autant de
réseaux wifi que deux voisins et ce qui
fait qu'au bout d'un moment ça sature et
a beaucoup trop de connections wifi et
quand on voit que tout le monde se
retrouve avec du 2,4 du 5 giga hertz le
fait de passer avec cette bande
supplémentaire en plus ça apporte une
bouffée d'oxygène et que c'est
postillonner sur l'objectif
donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant
maintenant il ya un inconvénient avec
les bandes de fréquences c'est de la
physique après a plu vous allez au haut
niveau des bandes de fréquences plus les
fréquences vont être courte en fait
l'idée c'est un peu ça voyez lorsque
vous êtes sur des fréquences plus basses
vous avez une espèce de ce passing
sinusoïdale et puis plus vous à l'aise
sur des fréquences hautes et plus ça va
être court comme ça et - la porter à
loin ce qui veut dire que si vous avez
par exemple une maison de 300 m² à
couvrir si vous n'êtes que sur la bande
ici 2 6 gigahertz ça peut rapidement
être compliqué parce que vous allez y
aurait des bandes un peu plus petit pont
c'est vraiment un peu arraché à dessein
comme ça alors ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que ces bandes là
c'est à dire en 2,4 giguère et en 5 giga
hertz continuer à coexister et vont vous
permettre de venir couvrir l'ensemble de
votre maison après il ya différentes
solutions iliad est répéteur wifi si ce
que vous allez pouvoir trouver dans le
commerce je sais pas s'ils ont
d'ailleurs été déjà commercialisé mais
en tout cas ils vont l'être c'est pas le
cas tout de suite qui permettront de
venir à couvrir une très grande zone si
vous en avez besoin alors ça c'est bien
c'est de la théorie on comprend un peu
les usages on voit que ça va aller plus
vite on voit qu'on peut en faire
davantage
on va encore pouvoir lire connectés
beaucoup plus d'objets combat moins
souffrir des connexions de ses voisins
on gagne un peu en débit ok ça c'est
intéressant mais qu'est ce qu'on va voir
mais rien en usage qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir venir faire ici avec son wifi 6e
et ben en fait vous avez différents
usages qui sont intéressants alors il ya
eu usage domestique un je vous dis une
fois de plus l'internet des objets à la
maison et ça c'est cool si vous êtes
gamer et que vous avez vous connecter en
wifi pour jouer parce que vous connecter
pas en filaire le mieux effectivement ça
reste le chilien mais lens par le wi fi
ce don va pas rester sur le filaire donc
si vous voulez jouer effectivement en
gaming vous allez gagner un petit peu en
l'attendant ça c'est plutôt intéressant
sur des jo qui va vous faire gagner
quelques millisecondes par rapport à vos
adversaires ça va également intéressant
pour permettre la démocratisation de la
réalité augmentée est virtuel terminal
est plus loin en tout cas si vous voulez
notamment dans la notion de metaverse
même si on n'est pas encore à 100 corps
une histoire un peu plus lointaine et si
on réfléchit à des usages plus
professionnel ça permettra d'aller plus
loin pour le cloud computing permettra
d'aller plus loin pour la télémédecine
dès lors que on se retrouve pas dans une
zone de campagne où on n'a pas de fibres
un futur conçoit fibré et qu'on est
derrière du wifi 6e donc ça permet
d'ailleurs plaint d' usage qui ne sont
pas que domestiques et qui vous permet
de faire beaucoup plus de choses et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse moi à la maison
j'ai une box ont mis six heures regardez
elle est ici c'est la dernière box de
bouygues telecom la dernière bbox qui
elle est en wifi 6,9 et grâce à cette
box j'ai pu faire un test lorsque les
équipes de bouygues telecom sont venus
nous installer et j'ai été quand même
assez surpris parce que c'est vrai que
ça marche vachement bien là ou en wifi 6
j'atteignais à peu près en descendant du
jt quoi j'étais à du 600-700 allez on va
se dire du 600 megabit par seconde ça
c'est ce que j'avais normalement avec ma
box wifi 6 et là avec la box wifi 6e
avec un galaxy s 22 ultras qui lui est
compatible wifi 6e par exemple si vous
prenez le dernier iphone le 13 promax il
n'a pas le wifi 6e la génération
suivante devrait la voir pour l'instant
cela ne l'a pas eh bien regardez je me
suis retrouvé quand même avec une bande
descendante à
1613 megabit par seconde et en attendant
j'étais quasiment à 600 mégabits par
seconde autant vous dire sa tartine
savant ça va plus vite donc je vois que
j'ai plus de débit et moi par exemple
qu'ils aient besoin d'entrer wifi ici
pour envoyer des fichiers directement
sur le web c'est vachement bien ça va
beaucoup plus vite donc c'est aussi ça
l'intérêt chez vous sur leur usage
domestique du wifi 6e ça va être plus
rapide on aura moins de latence alors la
question pour autant ces faut-il
aujourd'hui tout de suite en 2022 aller
sur du wifi 6e
première question à se poser c'est
est-ce que vos appareils sont
compatibles fils est ce que votre
smartphone et wifi 6es que votre
ordinateur accepte le wifi 6e s'ils
n'ont pas d'oubli fait 6e tout ça ne
sert à rien de changer il faut que la
chaîne soit complète et une fois de plus
on vient aligner les planètes avec up
ici une connexion en fibre avec à la
maison du wifi 6e mais surtout avec un
appareil compatible wifi 6e sinon ça
sert strictement à rien d'avoir une box
avec du wifi si ceux ci en face vous
avez aucun appareil qui peut se
connecter ci-après vous avez des besoins
de grosses connexion qui va aller plus
vite voyez par exemple ici en 1600
mégabits par seconde pourquoi pas après
le wifi 6 comme il est actuellement avec
une bonne fibre derrière ça va
parfaitement bien ça correspondait
vraiment à tous les usages donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le wifi 6e c'est pour des
personnes qui ont vraiment besoin de
latence très faible qui ont beaucoup
d'objets à la maison qui peuvent tous se
connecter en wifi 6e c'est la même chose
ainsi vos objets ne se connecte pas en
wifi 6e alors effectivement si vous avez
quelques petits appareils compatibles
bouffer 6e ça permettra un peu d'
apporter un peu d'oxygène directement la
maison parce que ceux qui sont wifi 6,6
restaurant sur deux quatre et du sein
les autres pourront potentiellement
monter jusqu'à 6 gigahertz pour apporter
un peu d'oxygène à tout ça ça peut être
cool parce que vraiment ça marche et ça
c'est prouvé je puis vous l'assurer
voilà je vais vous expliquer un peu ce
type le wifi 6e comprendre un peu
comment marche le wifi j'espère que ça
vous aurait dit que ça aura des gros si
un peu le tableau si vous avez des
questions sur wii fit sur wii fit six wi
fi 6e vous pouvez laisser bien
évidemment juste en commentaire on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech expliqué latex se balader
tester des produits et ça c'est très
chouette prenez soin de vous je vous
embrasse à bientôt de charge
[Musique]